Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so they just confirmed
a whole bunch of stuff about the Harley Quinn
movie that there making so I'm going to explain
what's going on Gotham city Sirens from the
comics and what Batman's involvement is going
to be there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway going on now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts that you
don't miss out on anything.
So what's going on we all knew that they were
going to make a Harley Quinn movie instead
of doing a direct suicide squad Sequel.
So right off the bat.
They were just like a couple really easy things
that you could take away from that one they
would probably find a way to work the Joker
and just because there was so much of them
together and suicide squad.
Whatever your opinion is about Jared Lehto's
performance as the Joker they kind of come
as a pair that he died for me what's will
you, but you can make a movie that just about
Harley Quinn.
She's the main character but the Joker just
so important to who her character is that
you have to include him in some way just like
you have to include Batman.
So even if they didn't originally intend to
do a lot of Batman in the movie he is definitely
going to be in their cousin of Gotham city
Sirens the title kind of gives it away, but
all explained that in the second to because
they were a couple different iterations of
the movie before they confirmed Gotham city
Sirens which is basically a Harley Quinn team
up, but nothing happens in Gotham city without
Batman knowing about it is not like he went
to the beach at them a scarab to just hang
out with the Amazons for a couple months so
Harley Quinn having a damn good time in Gotham
city at the expense of Bruce Wayne and the
bat are coming
you put on cards in the hospital you sleep
on the ground.
So there were a couple different versions
of the movie when they first announced at
first they talked about Harley Quinn team
up movie that could've been anything.
So we all just kind of thought Gotham city
Sirens that was the easy slamdunk.
But then later they were talking about Harley
Quinn and the birds of prey which is a very
different type of movie because even though
Harley Quinn has been featured in birds of
prey comics that's really like a superhero
team up.
Not a villain team up like Gotham city Sirens.
So if you never read the comics way back before
the new 52 like pre-2011 there was a title
with Catwoman poison ivy in Harley Quinn.
They call that Gotham city Sirens it was all
about their friendship.
Their adventures their relationship.
Just trying to get by as criminals in and
around Gotham city with all these other external
forces swirling around them.
You have the other villains like the Joker
who won't leave Harley Quinn alone then you
have people like Batman the keeps trying to
thwart them when they try to rob people rob
banks brought jewelry stores.
So it's kind of like a supervillain Thelma
and Louise situation whereby it.
Now they have the opportunity to introduce
the Catwoman character and poison ivy into
this DC extended universe which is really
important for number of reasons.
Because they just bumped the second Justice
league movie to make room for Ben Affleck's
Batman movie which is still on track.
But now they have the opportunity to introduce
some really cool Batman characters that they
can later use in that Batman movie without
having to over explain them again, so one
of the common problems with superhero movies
team ups in general is that they're too many
characters for you to develop really well.
So you wind up with a bunch of characters
that you just don't care about, so they introduce
a like a Catwoman character in this Harley
Quinn movie she gets a really nice arc she
becomes much more meaningful when you see
her pop back up during the Batman movie later
on.
So it should come as no surprise to anyone
that Batman is still the cornerstone of all
the DC movies Superman is one of the biggest
comic book characters of all time but from
a movie standpoint Batman has been much more
successful recently, so a lot of DC's extended
movie universe plans are tied to Batman success.
Ben Affleck was a great version of Batman
Margot Robbie was a great version of Harley
Quinn.
See you guys can let me know what you think
about them pulling some of the movie universe
in their direction.
I feel like it's good, but a lot of it just
depends on what the story the movies going
to be what is Harley Quinn Catwoman poison
ivy going to be teaming up for like what's
the whole reason for them to be together it's
the conflict is she fighting with the Joker
is she fighting with Batman.
Is she trying to steal something is going
to be a big Heise movie is gonna be like Ocean's
Eleven with a couple DC comic book villains
so what they should probably do is just borrow
a little bit from the beginnings of the team
in the comics so if you're not familiar with
the Gotham city Sirens comic book.
So what happens is is Catwoman poison ivy
and Harley Quinn are all laid low.
They're all sort of on the outs with their
respective male characters Catwoman and Batman
are at odds Harley Quinn is at odds with the
Joker and they find that poison ivy has seduced
and tricked the Riddler to use his apartment
as her new base of operations they'll come
together form an alliance they decide they're
stronger together and then go on to have a
series of crime-fighting adventures of their
own like they tried to do good.
But there villain, so a lot of times there
are whole areas consequences then eventually
like their loyalty to each other is tested
by people like the Joker like Harley Quinn
thinks about getting back with him she ends
up a train the team.
So you can see how it's a story that test
their humanity, their loyalty to each other
versus their loyalty to their own original
teams like even though Catwoman cares about
Batman and he cares about her.
She's a criminal so there always going to
be at odds.
So just feel like their giving Margot Robbie
the chance to build her character out like
a more fully formed Harley Quinn we saw little
bit of her and suicide squad we kinda saw
her origin story.
They didn't do a really good job of spelling
out how she feels about the Joker like is
very complicated.
So it's really hard to deal with unless you
get your own movie which they're doing now.
So what they might do if they want to keep
the character count from spilling out of control
is they'll just put Batman in the Joker in,
in addition to the core Gotham city Sirens.
So you have Harley Quinn Catwoman and poison
ivy teaming up to fight the Joker but then
you also have Batman that's trying to arrest
them to, so it's really the girls against
the two dues which I feel like would make
for a really awesome movie.
They haven't said anything about with the
actual story is going to be.
So it's all speculation, you guys can let
me know what you want them to do and who do
you want them to fight because there has to
be a reason for them to come together has
to be an evil antagonists and there has to
be the Batman antagonist is really the only
thing you can count on is that no matter what
they do Batman will try to arrest them by
the end of the movie.
The next big thing you guys been wondering
about.
They confirmed David Ayer is going to be directing
it so happy you are probably like WTF is up
with that the other have a prior like okay,
sure.
So what I think is going on is that he made
a really solid suicide squad movie when the
studios saw it they thought the audience would
respond to something a little bit lighter.
So he had all that drama within trying to
cut the two different versions of the film
and merge them and make something that turned
into a bit of a jumbled mess.
So I feel like they're confident in his ability
as a filmmaker like he can make good movies
it just that they need more time to write
the script.
David Ayer reportedly only had about six weeks
to write the suicide squad script that was
one of the biggest problems is not having
a real script that was ready, and to having
a very clear idea about what the film is going
to be in, given the reaction to all the DC
stuff during 2016 Batman view Superman suicide
squad.
I feel like they have a much better idea for
the target that they want to hit and because
the main lead is going to be Harley Quinn
the tone of the film will flow from her.
So if you want a good barometer for what the
film is going to feel like just rewatch all
of Harley Quinn's suicide squad seems they
actually just released extended version of
the DVD.
So there are more Joker Harley Quinn seems
to do a slightly better job of characterizing
their relationship which is incredibly codependent
and unhealthy home.
I'm just really he thinks he can take.
I would want to break those perfect porcelain
when the juice came, so given that I think
that the Joker will wind up being the big
villain of the film, but it won't start out
that way like they'll be something to drive
Harley Quinn away from the Joker and over
the course of the film Harley Quinn will come
to the realization that he needs to be stopped
and then eventually by the end of the film
she's victorious, but she ends up getting
taken back to Bill Reeve or wherever black
a prison or Arkham by Batman what about continuity
though you are asking like where does this
film fit in the timeline.
So obviously they'll pick up after the events
of suicide squad.
But they can get this movie and Batman started
in time than they can just have the end of
this movie role into the beginning of the
Batman film was can happen next is I'll post
my flash video.
I'll be talking about who the fastest flash
is like ranking all the members of the flash
family from fastest to slowest on how to do
that you do want to know when you see for
yourself will use them faster than Barry.
I'm saying that this point in his training
as to the so a lot of you are asking who is
the fastest flash, so that video post Wednesday
morning then I'll post some Star Wars while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here to watch the trailer for the next episode
of the flash and you can click here for all
my Justice League videos thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight!